we are trying to recreate the vet
Amitabh Iranians in better meat of the
show I Love Lucy was recently put on to
hula so for nostalgia sake i watch the
vitami - Vegemite episode in this
episode Lucy has eight tablespoons of
vitami - Benjamin and so in spite of me
that Benjamin is 23% alcohol she becomes
drunk by the end of the episode I wanted
to see just how drunk female comedians
would get if they actually had eight
tablespoons of 23% alcohol I don't have
I to be a measurement so I've diluted
some triple sec down to 23% so let's do
it
hello friends I'm your vitami to
Benjamin
are you tired run down listless do you
poop out at parties are you unpopular
answered all your breath pop problems is
in this little bottle by Tomita Benjamin
vitami division contains vitamins meats
vegetables and minerals yes with
vitameatavegamin you can spoon your way
to health all you do is take a spoonful
after every meal its tasty - oh God okay
[Music]
it's just like Handy's just like
guarantee so why don't you join
thousands of happy people puppy people
can get a great buy a great big bottle
of vitamin regimen tomorrow I try to
meet and veg Minh great job run through
it again okay
that's a mutiny German vitami division
Oh God are you in popular the answer is
yet is well and buy a great big bottle
of better petabyte German that's Vicat
mica regimen advisor sweetie
Aspen I'm a warm from warm is in this
little bottle vitami to veg better meat
a vitamin it's so tasty too oh shoot
vitae meat a veg emit where's our food
is it this one yeah oh don't wait like
take a tablespoon full after every moon
meal
I need the spoon I come to search have
you guys seen dr. strange that was good
getting better with drunk also one more
thing that I like to go is guess he was
the first person to stay pregnant on
television or seven without her she was
like with child or something that's my
to meet a measurement I didn't try to
wink when I am both went down I really
did it
this is it Kate okay
hello friends I'm your vitami to veggie
Mean Girl hey are you tired your enjoy
it all let's look oh yeah
well see who are the parties are you in
popular are you a popular well then
at KP answered all your problems in this
little bottle by Tomita Benjamin I'm in
renovage contains vitamins vitamin A
Benjamin contains vitamins meats and
vegetables and minerals yes with
vitameatavegamin you can spoon your way
to hell all you do is take a tablespoon
for after every meal so tasty too just
like
[Music]
it's just like candy so why don't you
join the thousands thousands of people
and three peppy people and buy a great
big bottle of bite to meet a regimen
tomorrow
because this isn't a time where you
can't order it online you got to get it
tomorrow it's weird though this
yeah well as you can order right instead
of today all right now in 19 minutes
free shipping and handling but no you
got to go to the store great great big
bottle of vitamin E vitamin Chamorro
that vitae Vita veggie man
that's right amita Benjamin this was fun
isn't one of my favorite Lucy moments it
was very fun to do it especially with my
best friend hot in here where you want
to go down some party okay we're gonna
go to pod you like whatever you get
drunk I see who you are ten years old I
go I used to be 10